economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela
comenzamos hablando de el salvador que
comenzó a usar el bitcoin como una
moneda de curso legal del curso legal a
la parte del dólar si santiago pues
entre protestas de algunos y
celebraciones de otros pero con bastante
incertidumbre el salvador es hoy el
primer y único país en donde la cripto
moneda más reconocida a nivel mundial
tiene curso legal quiere decir que todo
negocio está obligado a recibirla como
medio de pago los salvadoreños contarán
con una billetera digital llamada chivo
world y nadie buque le prometió un bono
de 30 dólares a quienes descargaron la
aplicación pero la alta demanda hizo que
colapsara y este mismo martes tuviera
que hacer suspendidas una economista de
salvadoreño nos explica los pros y los
contras de esta ley dentro de esos
riesgos se destaca que el salvador se
pueda convertir en un paraíso para el
lavado de dinero también por la alta
volatilidad que se pueda perder el poder
adquisitivo de las personas que se
cierren el acceso a crédito para el
gobierno especialmente en el marco en el
cual se estaba negociando acuerdo con el
fondo monetario internacional- por 1300
millones dentro de la ventaja que se
destaca es que se pueden reducir los
costos en el envío de la remesa a las
remesas para el salvado representan casi
una quinta parte de su producto interno
bruto esto obviamente si se hace a
través del agua la gubernamental chivo
que está siendo subsidiada con recursos
públicos daniela el salvador ya lo puso
en marcha pero no es el único país que
está contemplando esta posibilidad
sí señor el banco mundial en reiteró
este martes que no ayudará el salvador
en su adopción del bitcoin porque según
el organismo existen preocupaciones
ambientales y de transparencia sin
embargo hay países que quieren seguir
los pasos de el salvador veamos el
informe de jorge hurtado
una moneda virtual sin fronteras y
autorregulada toma fuerza el salvador
fue el primer país del mundo en darle
curso legal a la cripta moneda más
popular el bitcoin pero antes venezuela
y cuba ya dieron una bienvenida no
oficial según la firma especializada
análisis el uso de kriptón mono edad
creció ochocientos ochenta por ciento
entre 2019 y 2020 a nivel mundial y en
el ranking principal aparecen varios
países latinoamericanos en cuba' el
banco central anunció que legalizar a
las cripto monedas ante su creciente uso
las sanciones de eeuu le impiden acceder
al sistema financiero internacional
aunque con la tecnología blaustein los
cubanos podrán saltarse hasta cierto
punto el bloqueo según expertos
en venezuela los mineros de cripto
moneda se encontraron tierra fértil para
desarrollar sus negocios en parte por el
bajo costo de la energía eléctrica el
visto bueno del gobierno y es una forma
de generar ingresos pasivos
a diario
[Música]
y
los gobiernos de latinoamérica que han
adoptado el uso de las monedas virtuales
tienen varios aspectos en común por
ejemplo ser países en desarrollo tener
problemas económicos y una tensa
relación con los eeuu
la aceptación crece a buen ritmo en
paraguay prepara en un proyecto de ley
para atraer empresas de cripto monedas
mientras en honduras ya se instaló el
primer cajero automático de este uso y
en méxico algunos comercios ya reciben
el bit coin como forma de pago pese al
auge muchos organismos económicos se
muestran reticentes en parte por el alto
costo ambiental y su alta volatilidad
también la cambiamos de tema y un nuevo
golpe judicial recibe la empresa
francesa la fac pues el tribunal supremo
francés decidió que los jueces tendrán
que volver a examinar la posible
imputación de esa compañía por haber
presuntamente participado en la
financiación de grupos armados como el
estado islámico con una cementera en
síria la justicia francesa sospecha que
la faja entregó cerca de 13 millones de
euros a los yihadistas y sus
intermediarios entre 2013 y 2014 en 2017
la fiscalía de parís abrió una
investigación de la que por cierto no
hay condenas
danielle en las cifras ya para el cierre
se la tengo fresquita mire un dólar vale
hoy 00.00
bitcoins esa es la cifra pues mire hoy
cayó 17 por ciento el precio a su menor
nivel en un mes costaba más de 52 mil y
hoy cuesta 43 mil en apenas un día y
esto que hace que el salvador que tiene
550 pues haya perdido en un día
alrededor de 5 millones de dólares y es
todo un experimento gracias daniela por
esta actualización del mundo de la
economía es todo por el momento aquí en
france 24 buenas noches
[Música]